hey guys this is part two of our
reaction to the loki finale
uh if you missed part one there's a link
up here a card description box pinned
comment as well
if you're one of those people who's like
no i just want to see all the cool stuff
part two well
i just asked you check out the intro in
part one because i i have some nice
things to say
my methods are deceptive
but the mission never was without the me
without the
tva and what are you so afraid of
me and just who are you
oh i've been dubbed man
a ruler a conqueror
yeah you have eons ago
before the tva a variant of myself lived
on earth in the 31st century he was a
scientist
and he discovered that there were
universes
stacked on top of his own other versions
of us
were learning the same thing naturally
they made contact and for a while there
was peace
narcissistic self-congratulatory pete
i love your hair oh man nice nose thanks
man
not every version of me
was so so pure of heart
some of us meant only one thing new
lands to be
conquered the peace between realities
[Music]
erupted into all-out war each variant
fighting to preserve their universe
and annihilate the other wow this is
almost the end
ladies and gentlemen of everything and
everywhere
the timekeepers
[Music]
no this is where we diverge from the
dogma
first a creature created from all the
tears
in reality capable of consuming time
and space itself a creature you both
know
a lot of them think i harnessed the
beast's power
and began experimenting on it i
weaponized
goliath and i ended i ended the
multiversal walk
once i isolated our timeline all i have
to do is manage the flow of time
and prevent any further branches hence
the tva hence the timekeepers in a
highly efficient bureaucracy
and ages of cosmic harmony
hence you're welcome
i keep you safe if you think i'm
evil well just wait until you meet bye
[Music]
so you just continue to prune innocent
timelines
you two would there's two options
one oh kill me and destroy all this and
you don't just have wine nabo you have
an infinite amount
or oh my god you two run the thing
you're lying whatever
why would you give up being in control
ty and i'm older than that look
this game is for the young
the hungry i've gone through a lot of
scenarios
it's insane person to take this spot and
it turns out that person
came into oh
no more lies you kill me and the sacred
timeline is completely exposed
multiverse report or you take over
and return to the tva as its benevolent
ruler
you treated real people's lives like
some kind of
game it's not personal
it's practical
grow up sylvie murderer hypocrite
we're all villains here we've all done
horrible terrible horrific things
we you have a chance to do them for a
good
reason oh that's so weird
so twisted do the ends justify the means
i [ __ ] love him he's incredible
terrific yeah he's like
such an amazing killing man we just
crossed
the threshold
i flipped earlier when i said i know how
everything is going to go
i knew everything up to a certain point
and that point
was about seven eight nine ten seconds
ago
no idea how the rest of this is going to
go i've been candid
and now you're just going to sit there
with all that freedom and let us decide
your faith
yes what's the worst that can happen you
either take over and my life's work
continues or you plunge your blade in my
chest
and an infinite amount of me
start another multiversal war and i just
end up right back here anyways
reincarnation baby another
manipulation this is so dark i love it
i love this feels like a fresh start
what are you doing silly hangout let's
just
talk about it well how about we finish
what we started and kill it
no no no what if he's saying the truth
so what
i believe him you believe what that a
bazillion boogeyman are gonna turn up
just because we give people free will
he's a liar loki so am i and i don't
think he was lying
not about that insane yes but maybe he
was telling the truth but better hurry
timeline's already branched out
and what precisely is that to think
about what you're listening to what
you're saying
that's the gambit oh remove the dictator
what fills the void
you want the throne i don't believe you
silva the universe is in the balance
everything we know to be true oh please
trent trust him
i know the tv is how it is but what if
by taking him out
we risk unleashing something even worse
i promise you from my heart
this isn't about a throne what was i
thinking trusting you
is this whole thing minicon really
that's what you think of me
sure why not evil loki's master plan
comes together
oh you never trusted me did you oh oh
can't you see this is bigger than
our experience why aren't we seeing this
the same way
because you can't trust and i can't be
trusted
then i guess we're in a pickle so wait
wait
[Music]
oh he's begging maybe he's not
the cost of getting this wrong is too
great fine
do it kill me take your throne
no no
wow
stop i've been where you are
i've felt what you feel all i know
is i don't want to hurt you
i just want you to be okay
[Music]
okay just watch
[Laughter]
but i'm not here
[Music]
damn it
incredible
aren't you going to beg for your life um
good good i like how he's still in
decaying colors
[Music]
oh [ __ ] so is the king we're gonna get
later a different king
yeah oh they have it oh crap
whoa yeah this wasn't conqueror kang
that's gnarly so he remains ken
quantum media
[Music]
wow i love oh man and now the multiverse
yeah
this is crazy i love this
oh love it
[Music]
it's one huge debate
[Music]
followed by definitive action
oh my god look look at the time
squint and you can see toby maguire
oh lost him in the circus of time duder
this is insane
oh man
i'm turning back now it's like a kubrick
horror movie now
yeah for all time
always
oh poor guy
[Music]
that's what 63 new branches in this unit
alone
we can't it's don mobius we made a
terrible mistake
what's done we freed the timeline we
found it
a citadel at the end of time he planned
everything he's seen everything he knows
everything it's complicated
okay but someone is coming countless
different versions of a very
dangerous person
[Music]
what
oh no this is so
scary oh my god
damn that was wow
best finale of any of the marvel shows
so far
whoa mine freaking
blown right now i'm kind of like shaking
internally
so so dreadful and suspenseful and it
just took its
time to just let you imbue in the
horrific
nature of the circumstances and then
where they go with it
everything's just [ __ ] chaos this is
nuts
and he was great that that jonathan
major's back oh dawg oh dude
they let him just drink full-on just
walk around and enjoy
building that care it's like a one-man
show
oh my god that was amazing guys go watch
omni media who is it probably has his
reaction up right now
guy hustles really great reactor gives
great commentary as well
go check out omni media as soon as you
can but yes back to this
whoa god speechless i know right that
was
that was lots of times so many ideas to
spit out at once
i thought like if they introduced king
it might be a little too sudden but then
the the pacing and the writing and the
like yes his performance but the pacing
and the writing especially with how they
chose to
let you simmering in relish in it was
just perfect
oh wow what is this what a suspenseful
ass
ending when it's like a there's infinite
variance
this really is uh that's a dilemma
decide whether or not i'm lying
good luck because i didn't think they'd
shoot him yeah i'd shoot him stab him
yeah
because i was like oh it's going to be
an anime quantum main right
but the second he was like different
versions of me i was like oh
no no no no because because that was the
thing is like as it went on i was like
maybe this isn't conqueror kang man this
guy doesn't seem like that kind of guy
okay is there a post credit
[Laughter]
that was great the first one to end with
an established season two
first one to end i'm very excited about
that
i'm glad that they get to come back i'm
so excited
my testicles are just jumping around
like
like crazy like a volleyball in a
contained room a volleyball at a
nickelback concert just boom
everywhere yeah yeah that was amazing
like the thing in men in black that was
legit
amazing that was riveting and and i love
i don't know an episode like that that's
basically like a symphony of action
scenes but all comprised of just debates
all right disney plus is uh is they want
us to watch falcon and we're soldiers so
that means there's no post credits
yeah that was the post credits awesome
cool
all right let's talk about it oh my god
all right now the camera's not rolling
we could finally be a real selfish god
hates these marvel shows i know boring
episode
nothing happened nothing happened like
they didn't
fight at all i don't know limited on
actions like it's like really cheap
episodes
so loud i was a little over the top he
was just like being
silly gosh all right let's hit record oh
no what did we do
we're just kidding
okay holy crap guys holy crap so that
version
is more from our understanding
from all the things we've been watching
over the weeks that's closer to like the
immortus
right yeah not exactly like the same
origin but
but of all the kang variants i'm aware
of it seems like the closest to that one
it would be the closest to that one for
sure i'm sure
still it's you know like he doesn't seem
flat out malevolent
evil even though he's acknowledged that
he's had to do some nasty things to
create what he's created
i'm just gonna i'll probably just keep
calling him king all right
simplest way to go i'm going to keep
going he only alluded to all his
various titles yeah some call me a
conqueror you know it's it's cool
because it's like
you get he who remains but it's the
variant
yeah version of it that's neat that was
wild
that was a wild episode i loved how like
sci-fi dread horror it was it had bull
it kept
like the fantasy dread mixed with just
sci-fi horror dread
throughout like that whole time um you
know
jonathan majors is performing not only
did they just kind of let him have fun
with the role
the biggest thing i was noticing just
from my performance filmmaking
standpoint
was they really let him take his time
you know what i mean like there were so
many shots that just
they just let the camera roll there was
a lot of those
slow pannings slow pull outs that they
kept doing
yeah but i love that you know from a
performance level they're like oh you
just
you really were you felt like they
really respected him as an actor
yeah yeah and they let him perform they
let him
live in this like you as the audience
are getting to know
mortis nathaniel richards kang for the
first time
this is their first this is your
introduction to him
and this could have gone wrong like my
biggest worry about introducing kang was
it wouldn't feel like a lot it's gonna
probably feel rushed come on that was
like the biggest concern i had about
kang being in here
and they just like completely eliminated
that worry so early on once i saw how
they were capturing this
yeah absolutely absolutely and it just
it clues you into a piece
of a character who is to come and like
he said he's
one of many variants and so that opens
up a really cool
possibility just for what's to come not
only for you know the
kang the conqueror iteration that we
know of but also
other iterations who knows and i mean
like the performance jonathan majors put
on here like i'm
so excited to see him continue in this
world just because yeah like
so he could be funny and quantomania
exactly
for a lighthearted romp of a time uh but
no i mean like he he really had this
very
captivating quality where even though he
was like
partly undercutting your expectations by
being sort of
laid back and and bemused by all things
like it also really
hit me really well because i was like
yeah and it makes sense to kind of let
the camera roll and just let him play
because this is the guy at the end of
time you know he has
all the time and he was a per it's like
you you think king to conquer and it's
easy to be
like go to the most generic thing i
am kidding the conquerors look at my
purple head
yeah i love that the costume design so
put them in the king clothes
yeah like the the purple and green
looking stuff it was it was great um
yeah like there was there was such like
one the word that comes to mind is it's
so delicious how he's doing this
portrayal
oh yeah he's gonna savor every moment
yeah he gets to and it's
he's still a human being that was the
thing about king
about kang or this version of him is
that he establishes that i was born
i'm a person yeah flesh and blood i'm a
person and
my the persons of me got very carried
away
and i had to create this but i love that
there's almost this
like because he establishes that he was
like a professor or something right and
there does seem to be a little bit of a
professor preacher equality about him he
feels like a teacher almost who's been
at this school forever
yeah i was just you know giving you a
lecture in his off hours
uh and it felt like he there was a hint
of pain in that past too you know
like this person as a person there would
be pain there but you could see it by
the
moments that he was like provoked at
certain key points during the
conversations he was having
especially when he was feeling judged oh
yeah like i could definitely see this
becoming
even this iteration being manic at times
you know because i really bought it when
he said at the end like i'm tired
this is a whole lot to deal with and uh
even
in just one episode's worth of scenes
with him like i really
believed that of him you know
why it worked is because they let him
take his time yeah
there were so many moments this is so
important and it's often missing
in these you know like it's often
missing in these
um uh hold on a sec warren from cosmic
wonders calling me
yo warren we're filming our spoiler talk
right now
bye spoiler but you were right you said
a mortise to me three episodes ago and
and boy were you correct even though it
didn't say it that was totally who it
was yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna keep
calling him king
that's so true no no
we're just joking but dude
congratulations this is a big win for
for you and many people uh for me i uh
we started doubting around episode five
damn swinging for the rapture gut
next time i'm just going whatever you
say buddy there we go
next time i'll say it's my sister
mephisto is trending he said they were
hoping to kill the devil but yeah man
but we got to get back to this uh
talk but thank you buddy for everything
and and we'll be sure to decide oh
what's the best freaking thumbnail
uh later on today
i'll see you guys alright talk to you
later bud bye anyway yeah warren was
right
yeah he was good and yeah he knows his
stuff
you get the establishment of a life of
the significance of eliath more than
just a guard dog it was it was an
it was one that he he tamed well yeah
and that was brought forth
by his various experiments and breaches
of
the different you know veils between
universes and all that and i thought
that was great too is like even
that is sort of begat of his own
transgressions and
something that he has to reckon with and
build into this
weird band-aid he's built for all of
time and space
i could spend literally forever just
talking about his bemused performance
yeah that's what i mean so i was like
how did you pull this off so well
how'd you like man does you feel like
someone who's lived forever
and yeah yeah you still feel so like
you're you're real in your performance
but but larger than life at the same
time
it's like meeting the wizard but
actually it still being impressive in a
weird way
instead of being unimpressive like he's
not exactly who you'd expect but
again like it's it's been a while since
i can think of a time where there was a
performance of a character where it's
like okay you're waiting for the reveal
of
whoever this might be and then we get an
episode that really just
allows that character to be the
centerpiece and to just you know express
and like there's a lot of you know
there's some exposition in there there's
some brand new information in there but
it all
feels very vital and it all feels like
this
big this is the reveal episode this is
of course you're gonna get the
exposition yeah absolutely but it all
feels
like it's a part of this really big
debate that is happening right now
that's the other thing is like
like kang is a great centerpiece but
also
the debate he brings to the culmination
of the season
i love that choice he gives you yeah i'm
like that's a great
dilemma you have put your characters in
yeah do we rule this tva do we believe
him if we kill him this will we make
things worse this is and then
how they kept the choices character
based was the smartest thing they could
have freaking
done one thing that i was also concerned
about with introducing king and it looks
like this is kind of
what's happening is that most of the
conversation will be about about
uh nathaniel richards and mortis king i
guess we have to say it every single
time yes
yeah i'll learn the other ones too
what's his what's his uh egyptian guy we
got to get him in here as well
yes so yeah like that's going to be the
big conversation it's going to be the
future of what's going to happen
at the same time though i still felt
like they completed their season 1
story arcs of these characters that's
um something that i was kind of
concerned we wouldn't really
we would rush past when they didn't they
kept it all really
you know pertinent and it's really
important in the moment
you could feel the pulse of the show
like the the ticking time bomb of
oh i don't know what's going to happen
now was
great because you're like oh like it's
so sinister
knowing that he knows everything like
you see the transcript like damn even
this was supposed to happen
all this stuff about nexus events and
we're breaking the rules of the timeline
oh that's all within the timeline one is
part of the matrix that is insane yeah
like that was
that's what was blowing my mind was like
even right to this very conversation
like how do you
how do you beat this and the only way
they can beat it
is if he allows them to get get a shot
at beating yeah he like literally just
gives them the opportunity to
to create the circumstances of give the
power of choice and see what happens
you know absolutely but he's probably
someone wise enough where he can
anticipate the next steps
it's like what does he have to lose he's
dead he doesn't have to suffer through
any of this well yeah that seems like
ultimately for him especially
here and now it's like i don't know he's
probably just fine dying yeah
he's he's been around forever yeah he's
been around forever he's lived so many
lives he seems like he
for all intents and purposes is the
person who really
pierced the veil of and establish this
multiverse like yeah if anybody wants to
check out
this guy uh so a lot of the conversation
will continue to be about him
and the plans and all that um and then
of course like that crazy ending
with uh the branches oh they said
already 60th so i'm like how do they how
are these
next marvel how are they going to start
you know what i mean like what is the
beginning of these marvel movies
everyone's just screaming that's what it
feels like because
and that's the thing is they've done a
really good job of building up the
stakes and the consequences because when
you come back to the tva
i mean when you see the actual like
personification of the sacred timeline
starting to branch like that is
awe-inspiringly horrible
and then you see the ad just the screen
at the tv and you're like oh
this looks so much worse than just a
couple
spider-men smashing into each other but
they but they throw you into such a
hopeless situation with loki because you
they have that
lingering shot on him on just of all the
devastation that is going on right now
yeah you know
and and all the conflicting emotions
that must be going through
loki's um like tom hiddleston that one
shot that's just panning on him before
he's like i need to go out there and do
something
i need to go tell mobius and you know
that that moment where
you know what i'm talking about um yeah
i spent a long time describing the shot
to you when i feel like you probably
knew right away
so yeah that uh that that in that moment
um
you know the the thoughts of like i
could have done more
uh maybe if i was better she would have
trusted me yeah
oh my god what did we do because i
noticed when he goes to mobius he says
we
he's not like still [ __ ] up right now
he's saying
we did it we messed up and
um it was and then it has this almost
planet of the apes esque ending
yeah yeah with uh with the statue
um you know it does kind of make you
that statue of liberty moment but not
fully yeah yeah yeah it's but time's
being rewritten
this is off this is wrong it's uncanny a
little bit
time's in a different timeline already
within the tva
yeah the tva exists out of its own
bubble but now it's like everything's
just so out of whack
yeah yeah it's multiple yeah i know it
seems like maybe just like the
boundaries between all these different
dimensions and realities on top of each
other are just yeah starting to flex and
wave
yeah so maybe he's in a horrible
draconian you know fascist
maybe it's gonna be that it's gonna be
that rick and morty episode where like
every tva he shows up at for a little
while is gonna be the fascist dictator
version
well what i love about the about what
they're establishing here
what you could do with jonathan majors
is this is not a villain we're going to
keep building and building and building
to
for all these movies then we get to him
and then like let's see if it pays off
yeah it's like no let's we're going to
live with this we're going to live with
jonathan majors for a while
okay you know he's going to appear
multiple times
and as different versions of the same
guy yeah i don't know the extent of how
far they'll go
yeah uh regardless it's so cool that you
know when you think about like thanos
like oh it was like a little little blip
here and there
[Music]
you know a little segment here or there
and then okay let's okay we're finally
at infinity war let's see what he's like
here you're like oh
damn this whole episode was this is his
episode yeah absolutely but back to the
characters of like loki and
and sylvie they kept it character driven
on these choices it wasn't about
logical conclusions so much you know
loki is
i'm a liar i can't be trusted so i can
tell
when this guy's lying and when he's not
lying and so we got to think about the
consequences whereas sylvie her
issue she can't trust so their core
wounds and their and their that that
becomes
their ultimate downfall that becomes
their fate
is uh their pain of this like
established timeline this their
their own pain
essentially screw them in the ass you
know yeah yeah yeah i mean
and it's beautiful the way it comes down
to ultimately like i love the debate
that they made out of that because
ultimately like
you know it is that they they
acknowledge like
clearly we have a connection to each
other and clearly
we are challenging each other to grow in
various
worthwhile but very uncomfortable ways
but it all comes down to yeah she's
still
it's like a more loving version of
you know they've been like fighting back
and forth like kill me just like if you
need to
you know to to achieve what you think
you know is the right thing in this
moment and then she chooses this sort of
it's like it's her will ultimately but
she
does it compassionately to him shoving
him back into the tva
but then ultimately still going through
with you know
her goal all along that's what i mean is
she there was never
it seemed like she could not allow
herself to even think of the possibility
that this guy's telling the truth
yeah absolutely yeah uh because of i
mean it's not it's more than just
sylvie has trust issues like she's been
after this guy her whole life
yeah there's no way she's gonna like buy
into anything that
that concludes and he gets to live yeah
absolutely uh one and it rang so true
when she says like why don't why aren't
we on the same page about this yeah
because i really
super believe that as they're two
different people yeah yeah absolutely
and the
the very real argument that applies to a
lot of things of
of yeah like you know wait wait wait how
do we know that we're not going to
create a vacuum that's just going to
invite in something way way worse but
also
this even if we go back and try to use
this thing for good it's just not a good
machine
so what do we do like it's a great
conundrum it's a great shakespearean
tragedy
in that moment between the two of them
yeah you know like
we do love each other we do just want
each we we
you know especially loki and talking
with her you know like he starts crying
it's great performance with tom
hiddleston thank thank god for that guy
he's so great in this
tom hills is amazing yeah um uh i still
don't know the the actress who plays
sophie sophia di martino
she's great too yeah everyone's great in
here but yeah that moment was
heartbreaking
um but yeah the arc of loki and sylvie
in this episode too
uh just this whole story all around like
they've like i feel like loki's arc
really came full circle in the last
episode yeah
and this was it wasn't just merely set
up because this was the
completion of loki and sylvie for now
yeah you know
yeah yeah and the setup for what's to
come and uh
wow i don't know how silvia will feel
about all this though i can't wait to
see how she feels about what she's done
yeah yeah i can't wait to see where and
how she factors into anything moving
forward because they're you know with
each one of these passing shows
especially one division and loki there's
like
oh they're gonna show up to some degree
in other marvel movies coming up
and uh and and yeah i mean i don't i
guess expect
sylvie to show up in a bunch of other
mcus until loki season two but at the
same time like
she is kind of directly responsible
she's probably
she's the multi-first yeah yeah she's so
important so yeah she's
she's a super pivotal character now um
wow what a fascinating time we are
living in okay
yeah and like something that is so huge
in like a plot way but also in a yeah
character emotional
way well they kept it that way for all
the other stories too they kept those
interesting like
mobius having to confront ravona
learning the truth about her
it's it's like this this thing it's
this uh these characters are all
struggling with what their version of
their own personal truths are
yeah so much of this it's like ravona
all she has are her beliefs like her
whole life has been dictated by those
beliefs
you know what i mean yeah and like her
saying um
you know the one who gets free will is
the one in charge and she's like i'm
gonna go look for free will or something
so she's gonna
look for the one in charge yes so having
that but her character i loved her
performance here because it really
showcased
that this the tva has almost this
religious quality to it and she
to me is the best resemblance of that
theme
of the tva yeah of this person who's
like no god has to exist you know
yeah there has to be a reason why
someone is so dedicated to the dogma
yeah
yeah exactly so i uh and i loved her
that whole scene she had with moebius
and uh poor mobius
and no jet skis this season no chats
that's something to look forward to in
season two
well the big difference here is that
they really let us know there's gonna be
a season two the other shows they don't
make that clear
whether it seems like very up in the air
that they could change that this is like
we're promising you
the season two is a part of the slate of
the timeline
yeah of the importance of story of the
story for the whole marvel cinematic
universe
like season two is really important so
um
yeah uh you got that
and um the music in here is also
phenomenal absolutely that you have to
know how to properly conduct
and uh really choreograph the
especially the whole scene with kang
yeah it was like a tour to four scene
man damn uh
everything man even even just the sets
like i loved the
even though it's bare in a lot of ways
like i love just the look of
this you know biggest state that's we
got like
oh very token yeah it did yeah yeah i
don't like how we make tolkien
i don't know if it's i don't know what
tolkien really looks like that kind of
like
yeah cosmic cavernous black but with
those yeah just like you know
gold shards all throughout like it's
really
yeah and i love the opening establishing
with all the voices of
all the characters that everything's
gonna change and
and two like things yeah mixed in of
like you know there's also like the moon
landing and you could hear like
different like theoretical time and
space
like lectures in there like there's a
whole bunch of like that i'm excited for
the breakdowns alone because i'm like
what is the mishmash of the audio
samples there's a lot to cover
yeah um i thought this season
was excellent yeah i
i don't know where i'd it's a toss-up
between i would say like in terms of
gosh you know i don't want to decide
right now between one division or this
it's definitely not falconers but it's
it's they've all been special but it's
it's definitely a toss-up
here i mean because yeah this ends on a
cliffhanger note
and it's not really a criticism of the
show
like okay let's face it this whole thing
with like kang and multiverse that's
gonna be steal the spotlight completely
away from
the loki journey yeah you know what i
mean
because like so much of this was
learning to unknowing what's really
going on and who this guy is yeah
and uh and then like the biggest events
happen from that so i kind of
there's a part of me that's kind of
that's missing a like at
the time the slitherest the little most
minuscule
tiny bit sprinkle of
wanting it to feel a little bit more
emotionally resonant on the
chapter close for season one for the
loki journey
yeah not the loki world and tva but loki
the character the our main character
yeah um because this has been such a
great character journey for him
but i feel so i don't know i just love
this whole episode
yeah i know whatever we're gonna get a
season two so i can't i'm not that
perturbed by it because we're gonna get
a season two
yeah absolutely i mean so far
again it'll i'll i'll let the passage of
time truly decide but i feel like
this one might be my favorite so far
partly because i do appreciate that
while
like especially in the previous episode
i feel like you had some
action heights that like the thing is
it's weird even though i don't think a
lot of the actual hand-to-hand
fights of this show have been the best i
think they've made some
really amazing moments out of spectacle
that aren't what i'm used to seeing and
what i think gives this one for me
a bit of a leg up over one division is
that one division ultimately culminates
in something a bit more familiar to me
which is you know like a
witchcraft power battle um whereas this
came down to like a
huge debate and a big decision
that's gonna have massive ramifications
and and yeah i mean there is something
about one division where it is like
there's a different satisfaction and
having it be
pretty much intended to just be one
season that's so
great because this whole time and mortis
is saying
i created this because choice screws up
the multiverse
yeah and then he gives lets them have a
choice
and the choice made starts
instantly throws everything into chaos
yeah and that's the thing is it's weird
because it's like they both
have a villain yeah and it's like
well free will and you're like yeah free
will
but free will for everybody means free
will for all those freaking kings
you know and it's yeah it's like even
though yes i guess
in a way you always want to come down on
the side of free will like they they do
a great job of showing you what a hard
choice that is your choice
i wouldn't know what to do no i'm glad
that wasn't up to me
smart thing would be to keep take over
the tva but have
connection with king yeah if he'll stick
around and be your creative consultant
at the end of time i mean you gotta miss
me i'll miss minutes dude freaky ass
business
really is number one too yeah to him
though that's the
right hand gal that's the big reveal
about miss minutes because she's kind of
she plays it the most like sinister
number one
like the doctor zola oh yeah number one
she comes back to rensselaer like
yeah here's some fizes what you asked
for here's some files
make what you can out of these all right
we don't really know still who miss
minutes is or what miss minnesota she's
mephisto
but but you see that oh she she is like
um the number one servant to king like
kang is really the one calling the shots
and she seems to have a level of yeah of
sentience
i love that he getting introduced if
he's eating an apple like this god like
the beginning of time oh yeah
it's such an adult
and they make that again like it's it's
it's so
you can taste the juice
such a great this was well shot in the
scenery literally
um yeah and then also one division had
the ralph boner
there's things that i like that i purse
that i have a preference for in one
division
um but i don't know i feel like i need
to rewatch both of these twice before i
really come down
absolutely absolutely uh or at least
watch uh
this show one more time for me this
didn't have a ralph but like the closest
this got to a ralph boner was like
ah the db cooper thing wasn't more you
know like kind of yeah and that's like
about all i could think about an
expectation thing
yeah and that's not even that important
or like oh no king loki but honestly
like i'm not even where's the king loki
shot
yeah i'm not sure because then i was
starting to think like is it going to be
a fantasy
is he going to like is he going to be
like when they started saying like you
can have you can rule them like oh that
must be what's in those shots is that he
he lets him you know get a taste of it
yeah when they're
talking to miss minutes like what is it
that we truly want you know yeah yeah
that's where i thought they were going
but and i can understand still why
people might be upset about that but
personally i actually i'm i'm like i'm
okay with that because then
i don't mind a red herring like that for
an episode you know because
what we gotta know is marvel will lie to
us now directly i mean we've known that
oh yeah but they are more apparent than
ever with their
loc there's no romance and there but
there is
um oh yeah jonathan majors twice this
guy's lied about it like
i don't think about that ant-man [ __ ] i
don't know anything about that loki
stuff
uh and then the trailer footage the the
two there's two shots in the trailer of
of king lo
of loki as king and he is not at all in
there
so i don't know maybe something was cut
out obviously something was cut out or
they just shot that to throw us off
yeah i can see it i see both being very
likely it's from a variant
version of the show because this show
has the biggest reveals to hide
yeah absolutely so they would probably
go the extra extra mile
it was pruned yeah it was a clip from
the wrong
timeline that got in the trailers
you're adorable gregory all right guys
well what did you think about this
episode of loki where would you rank
this show
overall between the marvel series um
what are your hopes for what's coming
things are about to get [ __ ]
insane and i cannot wait subscribe click
that bell hit that like button check out
omni media
um check us out on patreon i appreciate
all the love and support you guys have
been incredible
we'll catch you guys soon